Me compré zapatos nuevos
y se los quería mostrar a todos.
Se los compré a este señor,
este señor se llama Catalino
y vive acá en la estación Rosario Norte
desde hace 20 años.
Acá está Catalino dándome sus zapatos.
Y se los compré para la charla,
porque para mí es una ocasión muy especial
y quería estrenar zapatos.
Cuando estudiaba, yo estudié Publicidad,
cuando estaba en Buenos Aires,
estudiando en la facultad,
nos dieron un ejercicio
que consistía en salir a la calle
y cambiar algo
para ver cómo la gente reaccionaba.
Entonces lo que hice fue vestirme
como estoy vestido hoy
y me fui al Obelisco.
Y cuando los autos paraban en el semáforo,
en lugar de pedirles dinero,
yo les daba 1 peso.
¿Qué comprobé con eso?
Comprobé los prejuicios
que tiene la gente.
Porque apenas me veían acercarme al auto,
me subían la ventanilla
o miraban para adelante,
pretendiendo que ahí no había nadie,
que no había una persona
y realmente, creaban también
una situación incómoda para uno
que duraba hasta el siguiente semáforo
y se volvían a sentir incómodos,
ignorando a otra persona.
Las mujeres por lo general
ponían el bolso atrás.
El ejercicio fue un éxito
y así fue que conseguí trabajo
en mi primer agencia Agulla y Baccetti.
Después de eso pasé a Vega Olmos Ponce,
y en el 2001 me escapé del ruido
ensordecedor de las cacerolas,
yéndome a Londres con 1000 dólares,
una visa de turista y sin hablar
una sola palabra de inglés.
Sobreviví un año, trabajé lavando platos,
armando andamios
para obras en construcción
e instalando equipos
de refrigeración y aire acondicionado.
Volví de Londres deportado
por trabajar ilegalmente,
por trabajar el doble
de las horas permitidas,
pero la experiencia
fue la mejor de mi vida.
Regresé a trabajar de publicidad
durante 2 años en una nueva agencia,
hasta que recibí una oferta
de una agencia en Nueva York.
Y me fui sin pensarlo,
pero esta vez con un departamento pago
frente al Empire State
y un sueldo de 60 000 dólares al año.
Una experiencia completamente diferente
pero que podía valorar mucho
después de la experiencia de Londres.
Así fue que me puse de novio,
al poquito tiempo de irnos a vivir juntos,
recibo un llamado
de una agencia en Austin, Texas,
que me ofrecían trabajo.
Les dije, «Mirá acabo de mudarme
con mi novia hace un mes.
No puedo aceptar esto.
Ella tiene trabajo».
Y me dijo, le damos
trabajo a ella también.
Bueno, fuimos un fin de semana,
nos gustó la ciudad, nos mudamos.
Llegamos un domingo
y el lunes nos enteramos
que ella estaba embarazada.
Nos casamos, traje
a mis padres de Argentina
y nos casamos en Puerto Rico, embarazados.
Nos casamos embarazados,
pero muy contentos.
Y en el 2009 nació Elena,
que es el amor de mi vida.
Es esa beba que está ahí.
Cuando Elena tenía un año y medio
recibo un llamado de mi hermano,
yo estaba almorzando,
y me dice que mis padres habían tenido
un accidente de tránsito muy grave,
ni sabía cómo estaban,
sabía que estaban graves
pero había sido cerca de Rafaela,
viniendo de Santiago del Estero
y no tenían ninguna noticia.
Sin saber absolutamente nada
me tomé un avión.
Me esperó un amigo en Ezeiza
y me fui a Rafaela.
Y me encontré con esto.
Me encontré con mi papá en coma y...
(Solloza)
Y mi madre con todos los huesos quebrados.
Mi padre estuvo en coma
durante 10 meses hasta que falleció,
y mi madre estuvo seis meses en cama
con seis operaciones.
Esta es la última vez
que le apreté la mano a mi padre,
porque al principio
me escuchaba y respondía,
y después no respondió más.
Y regresé a Austin, a trabajar,
tenía que seguir trabajando.
Y como a los 5 meses
antes de que mi padre muriera,
tuve una discusión
con mi esposa por la mañana
y me fui al trabajo dando un portazo.
Y al día siguiente recibí
una demanda de divorcio
y me quedé en la calle.
Perdí a mi hija, perdí mi casa
y con mis padres
en esa situación en Argentina,
me quedé completamente solo
y me fui a vivir a la casa de un amigo,
a dormir en un sofá.
En ese momento yo usaba Instagram,
esta aplicación de fotos
como cualquier otro,
sacándole fotos a un cielo,
a un pajarito, lo que se me cruzase.
Y un día me encontré
con este señor y pedí sacarle una foto
y le di 1 dólar por la foto
y me quedé hablando con él,
y me contó su historia.
Y de repente todos mis problemas
se hicieron pequeñitos
al lado de la historia de este señor.
Me sirvió para valorar
todas las cosas que tenía,
que no eran pocas.
Yo estaba saludable,
mi hija estaba saludable,
tenía un sofá para dormir,
que es un montón.
Y a partir de ese día me enfoqué
en hacer retratos de gente de la calle.
Encontré en ellos la familia
que me faltaba, el apoyo que me faltaba.
Sus historias me hicieron
valorar todo lo que tenía.
Y empecé a ganar seguidores,
y cada vez siempre ponía
la foto de ellos y su nombre.
Y si la historia era interesante
contaba algo de su historia.
Y en ellos encontré eso,
la familia que me faltaba.
Hasta que un día
me encontré con este señor,
estuvimos hablando,
le saqué la foto, le pagué el dólar.
Y antes de irme, este hombre me dice:
"¿Sabés lo único que me gustaría
hacer antes de morirme?".
Le digo "No". Me dice "Octoberfest".
"¿Octoberfest?"
"Sí..."
Porque me contó
que era descendiente de alemanes,
que siempre había soñado
con ir a Alemania.
Nos reímos los dos y me fui al trabajo.
Y en el camino al trabajo,
yo en ese momento tenía
como 5000 seguidores en Instagram,
en el camino al trabajo,
se me ocurrió la idea:
si cada seguidor que yo tengo
me dona 1 dólar,
que es lo mismo que yo les pagaba,
yo me puedo llevar a este tipo a Alemania
y puedo hacer un libro de la experiencia.
Y empecé a soñar con eso.
Y sin pensarlo mucho,
puse la foto de él con el titular:
"¿Quién quiere llevar
a este tipo a Octoberfest?".
Saqué una cuenta de Paypal,
armé un site llamado One Dolar Dreams.
Y de repente una señora desde Japón
me mandó 100 dólares,
y un tipo de Sudáfrica me mandó cinco
y uno de Estados Unidos me mandó dos.
Y me di cuenta que había
una idea importante,
que había una idea grande.
Mi padre fallece en ese momento
y un amigo que vive en Colombia me dice:
"¿Por qué no te venís y te quedás en casa?
Olvidate un poco de los problemas".
Me saqué el pasaje
con millas y me fui a Colombia.
En Colombia hice fotos.
Mientras mi amigo trabajaba,
yo iba a la calle y hacía fotos,
y escuchaba historias y anotaba nombres.
Y me di cuenta de la realidad,
tan diferente a la realidad
de Estados Unidos,
como la de cualquier país
de Latinoamérica.
La realidad de la gente
de la calle de acá es muy diferente.
Me encontré con este chico,
que me pidió dinero
para comprar zapatillas,
como sabía que se iba a gastar
el dinero en otra cosa,
fui con él y le compré las zapatillas.
Acá se está probando las zapatillas
y acá está contento
con sus zapatillas nuevas.
Seguí sacando fotos,
hasta que me encontré...
Así duerme la gente en Colombia.
Esto es parte del paisaje,
no nos damos cuenta.
Fíjense como la gente
pasa caminando, no existe.
Es un tacho de basura más.
Miren por donde pasa ese colectivo.
Hasta que me encontré
con este chico, que se llama Alex.
Alex venía de un pueblo del interior,
y había llegado a Medellín
a tocar la guitarra en los colectivos,
y era adicto al paco.
Fue a comprar droga
y cuando salía de comprar droga
lo cortaron con una navaja
y le robaron la droga,
la guitarra, las zapatillas, todo.
Llevaba 3 días en la calle,
con los pies hinchados, no podía caminar.
Y en la mano tenía un papel
de un centro de rehabilitación.
Y me contó que no aguantaba más,
que había ido a pedirle a la policía
si lo llevaba al centro
y la policía no le había dado pelota.
Entonces le pregunté
si realmente quería rehabilitarse,
me dijo que era lo que más quería,
que no aguantaba más.
Nos tomamos un taxi
y lo llevé al centro de rehabilitación,
me convertí en su padrino,
y Alex estuvo en el centro por 10 meses
hasta que salió y consiguió trabajo.
Volví a Austin y me mandaron de la agencia
a filmar un comercial a México.
Hice el comercial
y después me quedé un fin de semana
largo en la casa de un amigo,
e hice fotos en México.
La primer foto que saqué es este nene,
estaba pintado de payaso,
pidiendo en el semáforo,
y sus papás estaban en la esquina
tomando vino y esperando que trabaje.
Esto es México, muchos niños en la calle.
Y seguí juntando historias y contando
todo en vivo a través de Instagram.
Y ganando seguidores
y la gente dándome aliento,
lo que me hizo muy bien
para mi historia nuevamente,
mi historia personal,
y también para el hecho
de que siempre trabajé en publicidad.
Me gustan las ideas,
soy un apasionado de las ideas,
y de resolver problemas,
pero no soy un apasionado
de vender chizitos que tienen Monsanto.
¿Entienden? Entonces encontré
en este proyecto
algo que realmente me llenó la vida.
Tuve que ir a editar
el comercial a Los Ángeles,
tenía que editarlo
desde un miércoles a un jueves,
y me quedé el fin de semana en la calle,
no tenía dinero, me quedé en la calle,
e hice fotos en Los Ángeles
compartiendo la experiencia en vivo
a través de Instagram.
Saqué fotos en Los Ángeles
y luego llego a Austin,
en Austin encontré a este señor.
Este señor estaba sin trabajo, era chef.
Lo llevé a un negocio,
le compré todo el equipo de chef,
un set de cuchillos
y fui con él a diferentes restaurantes,
y les ofrecí publicidad a los restaurantes
a través de mis redes sociales,
para que consiguiera trabajo.
Y consiguió trabajo
en el primer lugar al que fuimos.
Me invitaron a dar una conferencia
a Uruguay, me fui 10 días antes.
Hice fotos en Uruguay.
Y para la conferencia de Uruguay
lo que hice fue agarrar
un chico de la calle,
que es este, Sebastián.
E hice algo al revés
de lo que hice hoy acá.
Lo vestí a Sebastián de publicista
y estuvo en una habitación
de hotel con ropa nueva,
mezclado entre la gente
durante el festival.
Y ahí comprobé
que por el aspecto de una persona,
también pasa al revés:
si estás bien vestido, no importa
si sos alcohólico o "homeless"
la gente te va a respetar.
Me fui a España a lo de un amigo,
es buenísimo tener amigos
por todo el mundo.
Hice fotos en Madrid durante 10 días
y una periodista a través de Instagram
me ofreció hacerme una entrevista.
Después de la entrevista me ofreció
su departamento en Barcelona
y me fui a Barcelona
y estuve 10 días en Barcelona.
Haciendo fotos en Barcelona.
Después de España, todo esto es España.
Muchas fotos en España.
Me invitaron a El Salvador,
allí hice lo mismo.
Me fui 10 días antes,
hice fotos en El Salvador.
Pero para El Salvador,
lo que hice fue ponerme en contacto
con la madre de un asistente
a la conferencia,
sin que el asistente supiera
y la disfrazamos a la mamá de homeless,
hice fotos de su mamá vestida de homeless.
Entonces cuando estaba mostrando
las fotos como hago ahora,
de repente apareció la mamá
de este chico, que es esta.
Nadie sabía nada, él solo,
pero él ya no vio a la gente indigente
de la misma manera.
¿Por qué? Porque cuando esa persona
es alguien querido,
la perspectiva cambia,
cuando es alguien
a quien le tenemos cariño.
Y estas personas que viven
en la calle son hermanos de alguien,
hijos de alguien,
madres de alguien, todos.
Después regresé a Austin
y tenía ganas de hacer
un estudio más grande de Estados Unidos,
porque había hecho
solamente Austin y Los Ángeles.
No tenía dinero,
y de cualquier manera,
como todas las otras veces agarré el auto
y me fui con 1000 dólares,
la misma cantidad de dinero
que me había llevado a Londres.
Y agarré la ruta, estuve dos meses,
recorrí 10 000 millas, durante dos meses.
Hice Las Vegas, Los Ángeles,
San Francisco, Denver,
Saint Louis, Detroit, Nueva York,
Washington, Atlanta, Miami, Key West,
Nueva Orleans y regresé a Austin.
Ahora la gente me abría
las puertas de sus casas,
me dieron dinero, me dieron comida
y mucho pero mucho aliento.
En San Francisco invité a un homeless,
a un chico que estaba en la calle,
a venir conmigo,
y viajamos juntos durante
un mes y lo dejé en Key West.
El viaje fue un éxito.
Y, por último, les quiero
hablar de la suerte.
De su importancia, porque muchas veces
discriminamos a la gente
simplemente por su apariencia,
pero no tenemos en cuenta
que es todo suerte.
Ustedes tienen mucha suerte
de estar hoy acá,
escuchando esta charla y bien vestidos.
La suerte es un factor fundamental,
no solamente en las cosas
que a uno le tocan,
sino en las decisiones que uno toma.
Porque todo eso determina
lo que uno va a decidir más adelante.
Por ejemplo, este gorro que yo tengo
es el resultado de un padre
alcohólico y abusador.
Este gorro.
Este saco, es mi hermano
que me dio pegamento
cuando yo tenía siete años,
eso es este saco.
Estos zapatos que tengo puestos,
son el no haber ido a la escuela.
Los zapatos de Catalino
que duelen, duelen mucho.
Esta camisa que tengo puesta...
es porque me pegaron en el barrio
las amistades, las buenas amistades.
Y finalmente, estos pantalones,
estos pantalones son mi mamá,
que trabajaba de puta
y no estaba nunca en casa.
Somos todos iguales,
como ustedes pueden ver;
diferencias más, diferencias menos.
Yo siempre trato de estar agradecido
por lo que tengo
y no preocupado por lo que me falta, ¿no?
(Aplausos)
Este...
Este calzón
es haber nacido en el Sanatorio Británico
con médicos de primera línea.
Eso es este calzón.
Esta camiseta, es el haber ido
al colegio Maristas
desde el jardín hasta el secundario.
Martín Jáuregui: Esperá que te ayudo.
Seguimos aplaudiendo ¿no creen?
(Aplausos)
Pachi Tamer: Planchada por mi mamá.
Anoche me la planchó
mi mamá que está por acá.
Este pantalón es el haberme equivocado
de carrera 3 veces,
y mis viejos que me bancaron
hasta que encontré lo que me gustaba.
(Aplausos)
(Fin de aplausos)
Finalmente estos son mis zapatos,
los que visto todos los días
y que representan el esfuerzo de mi mamá,
que con 74 años sigue trabajando
para que un puto divorcio
no me deje en la calle.
Estos son mis zapatos.
Y les agradezco a todos
por habérselos puesto por 18 minutos.
Gracias mamá, gracias a todos.